if you're sitting and watching right now
and you're 28 and you don't have
end you can get like it's okay just cuz
you're not winning at 23 or 27 or 32
you're not finished we're in the first
quarter I started my company at 34 years
old in another company's conference room
cuz we had no money I was 34 before I
ever made $100,000 a year how old are
you I'm 2 27 you got time like you can
go hard for 3 years do nothing right
wake up and be young as what is is it
time to panic 70 70 cuz Colonel Sanders
came out with some KFC it's late there's
some people watching right now that are
25 and they like feel like sad because
they're not a millionaire that's asinine
like you can accomplish a lot everyone's
so anxious everyone wants it so fast
everybody wants to keep up with the
Joneses they want to make it now so they
can show or enjoy like to me enjoy the
process of your career not the money you
make from your career so you can then
enjoy it and that's the game I play